[Music]
all right you guys it's time for the
matinee show this is matinee what 68
something like that right so we did two
movies in the theater this week and one
shutter original so we're gonna start
with that one so this is a brand new
movie just came out on shutter it's
called the marshes this is an Australian
movie directed by Roger Scott and it's
basically I mean the plot of it is like
there's three biologists their names are
pre abandoned will I think and they go
out into the outback to take like water
samples because there's been like a lot
of ecological damage like out in this
particular area before they get out
there there's kind of some [ __ ] with
some horrible Australian type rednecks
that they kind of have some exchanges
with out in the outback but there is
also a guy possibly supernatural I'm not
really sure but he's what I guess what
they call down there a swagman which is
kind of like a guy that wanders around
the outback like hunting rabbits and
whatnot walks her on the bag they talk
about him in that song waltzing matilda
yo that we call those bums here yeah
well I mean not really a bum I mean he
just like sort out in the out yeah he's
like a survivalist he like he lives out
in the outback but like I said I think
so at the beginning like when they're
kind of camping and they talk about this
urban legend about this particular
swagman that's like in this area and
stuff like that and you know spoiler
alert it ends up being a real guy or hmm
there's also some hint that maybe
everything is just in Priya's head I'm
not really sure where they were going
with that um this is actually um this is
a decent movie but one it gave me it
gave me a feeling that this was like a
short film that they were stretching out
to feature-length
because I feel like a lot of it was just
kind of like filler with like the three
characters like walking around in the
underbrush there was there was like even
an extended sequence which was almost
exactly like the Stephen King story in
the tall grass where they were just like
stuck in this grass and they kept like
circling back to the same place and
stuff so that I mean it was kind of
given some depths a little bit I think
because they did have some ambiguity
over whether all this [ __ ] with the
swagman was really happening or whether
priya was imagining it for some reason
there was also like a lot of imagery of
like bugs like not bugs but like amoeba
like bacteria and stuff like that like
in the water so I'm not sure if they
were trying to imply that she had been
bitten by a mosquito because they did
kind of go a lot into like mosquitoes
and like before they got there like the
one guy was saying you know oh can we
get like whatever the [ __ ] [ __ ] is
that you get from mosquitoes not
encephalitis but the other thing the
other disease so he was like asking
could they get that so I don't know if
they were implying that she got bit by a
mosquito early on and then she was
hallucinating all of this and they never
really revealed whether that was the
case or not like I'm guessing that like
the [ __ ] hunter and everything like
that was real because she saw him they
saw him like at a gas station before
they went out there but they spent so
much time with like the bacterial
imagery and her having like weird dreams
which apparently up somebody's hand like
on the outside of the tent and
apparently wasn't hat it didn't happen
so I'm not really sure if all of this
stuff happened or not you know what I
mean
which usually that doesn't bother me but
for this one I think they were trying to
go for something and it wasn't super
clear what they were trying to do like
it's not a bad movie um the
cinematography is really nice reminded
me a lot of and the look of the swagman
reminded me a lot of like Wolf Creek and
like movies like that had a couple of
you know kind of gory scenes of the
swagman like cutting a dude open like a
pig and like eating his liver or
whatever the [ __ ] it was he was doing
but it was like very it was cut very
quickly you know what I mean Australia
lately Australia's kind of been bringing
to a game with some of these horror
movies I think that last two or three of
them that we saw I like them yeah I did
well this one is not quite the a game
yeah it's more like the B game now I'm
not I'm not [ __ ] on the director or
the the crew or the acting the acting is
good I think yeah it was shot really
competently whoever made this movie has
a lot of potential yeah but I think it
just needed to be brought up a notch the
story wise or should
like you said it felt like a short story
stretched out yeah because there was a
lot of there was a lot of footage of
them just like walking around lost or
like walking around in the outback I
think had the budget been a little bit
bigger the script been a little more
detailed you know I mean more [ __ ]
happening in it it would have justified
the length yeah because that's what
that's the problem I'm seeing with the
movie yeah I mean I liked the concept I
liked the swagman concept I liked kind
of the not necessarily red herring but
there was also like a secondary threat
like with this scary hunter dude that
was always out there who was clearly a
real person and also a huge douche bag I
also liked the introduction of like this
bacterial thing and like I said I think
they were trying to go somewhere with
that because they did make a big deal
about you know can we get [ __ ] from
mosquitos out here and all this other
stuff and showed people getting bit by
mosquitos like hitting themselves so I
do feel like there was some of that
going on so I liked that ambiguity thing
like oh is this wag man real is she just
imagining it because she's having like
fever dreams and stuff so I liked that I
just felt like you know and like you
said the actors were fine they were
likable you know relatable characters
the cinematography was really beautiful
it just felt like there wasn't enough
like story to it yeah what's the
director's name Roger Scott okay I'm not
sure this might be his first maybe I'm
not entirely sure well you probably keep
an eye on him I that's what I think I
think I think I think better will come
from this guy I think it was budgetary
problems
I think so too you like I definitely got
the feeling that you know not only was
this a very short script that they were
trying to make into a feature like the
movie and it's not even that long a
movie I think it's only 85 minutes um
but I definitely got this sense that
they have we're having a lot of
budgetary constraints yeah because like
a lot of the gore looked really good
like it looked realistic like that the
guy was cutting it open and like eating
it but they didn't show it for very long
like it was very quickly edited almost
like well that's probably good idea cuz
if I wasn't much going on yeah because
like they made it seem like there was
yeah like they didn't want to like dwell
on it too much in case it didn't look
good in Opera and they didn't have like
a lot of big gory set pieces or anything
like that probably because they couldn't
afford it like I said you know I don't
like to [ __ ] on people too much for not
having the [ __ ]
and money to make a movie oh well no I
mean you guy didn't have any money and
you made a decent movie yeah it's a
decent movie that's what I mean you know
it's not a bad movie yeah I just you
know the only thing is I felt like in
the Middle where they were just kind of
like wandering around and you know
there'd be long sequences where there's
wandering around and they would just
hear the swagman whistling and stuff
like that which you know that's creepy
up to an extent but after a while you're
just kind of like okay let's get on with
it you don't mean like let's move on to
something else
so I think that was the only thing that
was inked I think it made a point that
he can make a movie yeah all right I I
kind of predicted that a better one will
come from this guy yeah I think so too
and like I said if this is his first
effort which I'm not sure if it is um
you know this seems like a really good
movie I generally like all new movies
that are coming out of Australia we've
reviewed a few of them on the last show
so like I said this you know it's not
fantastic or super memorable or anything
but it's like a you know it's a
completely competent good low-budget
movie maybe mine yeah and you know
that's kind of the only complaint I had
about it that it was just like a little
slow and they were kind of like you're
massaging this [ __ ] out yeah yeah yeah
and that they were kind of like
hamstrung by budgetary concerns which
like I said not completely their fault
but but you know if you know if you want
to check it out if you like Australian
horror like I said it's got kind of a
little bit of a wolf's creaky kind of
vibe not quite as over-the-top as that
you know over-the-top gory over-the-top
upsetting or anything like that this is
pretty low-key but if you like that type
of thing it's came just came out this
year I think it just came out like last
week or something like that and it's a
shutter exclusive as far as I know at
least in the United States so go check
it out
you
okay second movie we took in this week
was the movie that just came out in the
theater called underwater I liked it as
well this this is like I mean you know
it's not like a masterpiece or anything
but it was like way better than it had
any right to be yeah I mean the thing is
obviously an alien ripoff yeah but I'm
saying that you know in a complimentary
way it was done right they erode the
movie so econo fits in with the Ridley
Scott vision of the future of the Blade
Runner and alien and Prometheus it's
kind of like that it is like that I mean
you I don't think they're violating any
copyrights or anything but it's you know
the world that they're talking about
there's a lot of little when they're not
Easter eggs but they're little but what
do you call it a little shout outs to
those movies yeah
all throughout including like shot
composition you know they'll shout it
out and it's about some people trying to
survive
way down on this damn drilling rigs like
was it five four miles underneath you
seven miles in seven miles it was in the
Mariana Trench right yeah and it's
almost like another world down there I
think it was like four tons of pressure
per square inch yeah yeah you know
pressure is a huge problem pressure and
oxygen some disaster strikes rig starts
crushing itself and the survivors are
trying to figure out how to get to
another rig that's on the bottom of the
ocean for safety yeah and it thing's
huge you know this this rigs huge yeah
it's like an oil drilling Vegas yeah and
it it it kind of leads you to believe
because it has sections of it depended
am whole and out into the ocean in
because it's a big ol long damn tube
with buildings on the outside of it
gives you the impression that there's
thousands of people on it I got my god
well I think they said at the beginning
that there was three hundred and
something that was yes um but I think a
lot of them were killed in the initial
which isn't really a spoiler because
[ __ ] starts to go sideways about five
seconds maybe a minute
and it's a survival horror and it's
pretty much Matt's real close to in
concept and a remake of alien one it is
which which like I said that's not a
knock on it because that's a winning
formula it works and and they're not
really making any secret about now they
let you know that this is alien one
Connor this is alien one retold except I
got to say with a you know obviously
it's under the ocean instead of in space
also has a little bit of a Lovecraftian
thing going on yeah that might be a
spoiler though well Lovecraft's always
about sea monsters and you know there's
this is sea monsters yeah which up like
I said I don't I don't think that is I
don't think that's a secret either no
and and I've seen other reviews calling
it Lovecraft mean alien which exactly I
mean it's not it doesn't it's not
Lovecraftian in tone but it is very much
like it hits a lot of the same plot
beats as alien yeah and it has like a
lot of the same character dynamics um
that type of stuff where it's just kind
of like you know a bunch of work in
Joe's that are down in this rig [ __ ]
goes south and they have to like yeah
you know and they have to go through
this impossible set of like obstacles to
like try to save yourselves and lately
there's been like a big rash of these
movies with like really cheesy girl
power type [ __ ] themes you know this
is not one of those kind of movies this
is a lot more like the Alien franchise
where you have a heroine or female hero
you have her but she's not a super girl
she's just a mechanic and she survives
this [ __ ] through her wits and I liked
it I liked that [ __ ] play on it just
like even though this actress is kind of
known for movie that you know true
what's it called Twilight Twilight which
people are Kristen Stewart she's been in
tons of [ __ ] since then she gets rift on
it it's like everybody gets it still
[ __ ] about it I don't know this is the
first time I've seen this actress I
don't know a twilight I've never seen it
so for me it was just a fresh start and
I thought she was great in it
I thought she was like a Ellen Ripley
well she does a really good job and I
think a lot of the other cast members do
as well of being an a pride
particularly like the one like comic
relief character yes I like that he's
not a coward like he's always making
jokes and he's always talking about how
you know how he's [ __ ] himself and
stuff like that but he's like the first
one to go through it he knew something
like you know what I mean so because I
feel like a lot of action movies make
the funny guy
also the cow I liked that they didn't do
that in this case there's there are Cana
Blade Runner and alien-esque tropes in
it but it's good yeah but it's good and
none of the characters are disrespected
think about yeah everybody would
everybody did a good job yeah there
wasn't any [ __ ] losers or cowards
people what actually wasn't even any bad
guys in it no no I mean the bad guy this
was like a man versus environment or a
human versus a guys were the damn
monsters and the deep was yeah it was
like the [ __ ] [ __ ] that they had to
go through because they're seven miles
down in the ocean yeah well as one of
the characters very rightly says we're
not supposed to be what's this actresses
name again who the main one yes in
Stewart Kristen Stewart yes yes there's
another girl in it too
yeah Colleen from Iron Fist yeah I can't
remember what the actions name is yeah
well sure she has like a hand Mike
Stewart she's just got the short haircut
kind of Butchie looking but man she's
just cute as hell in it and she's not
being you know it's not like b-movie you
know overly girly [ __ ] you know
that's not what it is is like a real
person we were talking about like some
of those sci-fi original movies or is
like you see this [ __ ] she's running
around with no long nails and high heels
and [ __ ] fighting the monsters like that
somebody's like oh yeah I'm supposed to
be a mechanical engineer but she's like
she's just the worst she's just a work
in Jane really you know just and most of
the crew is pretty young witch which is
you know that kind of match matches up
it's they're all military age yeah it's
very much the corporation seems to kind
of have a military you know flavor to it
or a paramilitary flavor to it you know
not so much in uniforms but they are all
pretty well trained and they're young
and they're in danger so I guess that's
what that corporate
was looking for even their boss wasn't
that old yeah the captain the captain
yeah he was 40s yeah and finally I do
like that actor Vincent Cassel yeah and
it's a high risk environment and they
all know it yeah so it's like and
they're all pretty familiar with you
know the things that you do when
something goes wrong it's just that so
like it's such a catastrophic like a
breakdown that they have to really kind
of like fight their way across and it's
it becomes kind of a thing where you
know we're either gonna sit here and die
or we're gonna go out there and it's
like you know what I mean it's like they
they knew what they were doing you know
they try to replicate that dynamic of
the crew inside the Nostromo yeah alien
want and I think they did a good job I
think they did too and like I said like
I said it's not a masterpiece it's not
gonna win any awards or anything but
it's like it's very weird to me that
this movie was apparently according to
Wikipedia made back in 2017 and it's
apparently or 2018 and apparently it's
been sitting on a shelf for a while
because I guess nobody thought it would
be any good or they thought nobody can
see it yeah and they released it there
and they just dumped it in January to
January that's the [ __ ] movie that's
[ __ ] pretty much or movies worth studios
like they don't think it's gonna do any
kind of business and they just kind of
like throw it in January and then just
everybody find that so they thought the
same thing about that movie the Meg yeah
and the Meg was a very different movie
all right yeah totally
that was goofy er yeah I love the Meg
meg was [ __ ] funny
it was like a bigger budget like you
know two sharks and that kind of [ __ ]
you know like yeah like a sci-fi
original but it was very enjoyable and
it was traditional and it's layout well
this one is also count traditional in
its layout yeah and in the spirit of
alien 1 yeah so I liked it and like you
know like I said if you like alien if
you liked you know that kind of the
alien ripoff underwater movies that came
out I guess in the 90s like the abyss
and stuff like that maybe this is much
better
Leviathan or something like oh yeah I
actually liked this a lot better well
cuz I should say too that I mean be in
deep under water like in the ocean is
like one of my horrible fears and it's
like I've always had like when I was a
kid I would always have nightmares about
that like you would be in this really
deep ocean and then like this huge
monster would like come out of the
darkness toward you
so anything that plays on that is gonna
stress me the [ __ ] out yeah you could
tell that they you know they knew about
abyss and Leviathan
but I just think these are a totally
different tier of quality this is a lot
better quality yeah I mean I had I it
this is a really good and like I said
there's like a quiet moment at the
beginning where you know Kristen
Stewart's just in the bathroom brushing
her teeth or whatever and then like a
minute into the movie everything starts
going sideways and it's pretty much just
a non-stop yeah and you know some people
I think of criticize oh you don't get a
lot of character development and stuff
like that which you don't need that in
the movie lashes like this I don't think
and you get it in little bits and pieces
you get a sense of like the people's
characters it's not like it's more of a
plot driven movie like an action driven
movie by the movie than a character
driven but I think you get enough of the
characters that you care about them you
don't want them to die I mean you don't
I mean they give them little quirks and
stuff like I should have shot like
you're there with I'm trying to survive
this [ __ ] yeah you know I mean so it
doesn't the character development it's
not really needed it's just are these
people gonna survive how are they gonna
get out of this yeah and that's really
where the enjoyment is you know and
there's a Gary they're scares in it you
know I saw him coming yeah but it is an
eerie movie if you if you're free if you
thought alien was eerie and underwater
shed is eerie to me yeah since I was a
little kid you go to that damn
underwater ride at Disneyland we passed
that big old [ __ ] yeah big [ __ ]
underwater damn jaw knocked squid you
know was it a squid or was an octopus
and
I think it was a squid actually yeah
that underwater [ __ ] scary yeah and it's
kind of still does I mean pretty much
the whole time I was watching this movie
in the back of my head I was thinking
[ __ ] the ocean yeah I'm not going out
there ever yeah so yeah man I just I
just thought it's a good movie and now I
don't care what they say it should I
want to buy it it's a lot of fun it's a
fun like you know it's just a fun horror
movie like I said it's not gonna win any
awards or anything but and visually
imagine if Blade Runner 2049 was
underneath the water
they had them some of that yeah in it
and alien yeah but that supposed to all
be Kannada I mean it reminded me the
most of alien just you know the way it
was set up like you know the isolation
you know the the kind of like
claustrophobia yeah some of those
exterior shots of the drooling rig yeah
how big it was yeah
kind of reminded me of like you know I
mean the scenes are flying over this big
building yeah damn Blade Runner you know
and then I can't spoil the ending of it
the ending was very I didn't expect it
yeah I was like oh this is what kind of
movie this is yeah okay yeah I mean all
right I saw hints at it in the damn
locker
yeah when a guy when he broke into that
captain's Locker yeah and then he showed
pictures of the dev sea monsters and it
kind of looked like something out of
could throw you and like an HP Lovecraft
and one thing I wondered though is that
I wonder if they're trying to set up
like an extended universe type of thing
because at one point like the captain he
was the captain on the other rig that
they were trying to get to the abandoned
one right I don't know that yeah because
they like she found his locker and then
like but he somebody said earlier that
that was that there was nothing there
and then the company's covering all this
up so they kind of have a way Lenny
industries so I felt like I finally know
about something that's happened down
there and plus I kind of liked that they
didn't use a lot of exposition they just
like at the beginning and end
they had like you know like reports and
like like newspaper articles and stuff
like that
so if you read those you kind of got an
idea of what was going on like on the
surface but they didn't really go into
it in the movie they didn't have to
those
right that's what I mean either dig it
vague yeah the only thing I can knock
this movie for is that in the beginning
it opens up with monologue
yeah the although and it's not a lot of
it there's not a long duration in a
narration yeah a narration which that
was in Blade Runner 1 yeah to their own
certain cuts of the original cut of
Blade Runner but I'm going like why
don't we divisive in that one too yeah
why are they narrating here you know it
was totally unnecessary yeah you didn't
need to know any of that yeah you know
that's yeah that's true like I said
maybe they were just start maybe that
was added later like to try character
development but you know that was the
only time it only happened at the very
beginning in the very end the less I
knew about that girl I think the better
yeah I just you know I mean I wouldn't I
wouldn't give her any kind of backstory
yeah just because this week that's way
Ellen Ripley was they added back Street
[ __ ] later and a movie as it came well
like I said that's what Ellen Ripley
wasn't even written as a woman that that
character was written as a man of a
matter person a person unisex kind of
thing and that works out well yeah that
way there isn't any kind of [ __ ]
weird would he call it expect gender
expectations out of that character well
like I said if it's just a team and
that's why I worked well an alien is
because if it's just a team that's
trying to get a job done yeah it doesn't
it doesn't matter like you just do what
your job is and that's the end of the
story and that's what made a lien once
so great is that some of the [ __ ] you
were reading into it because you're
seeing a Ripley that is female you not a
man but originally the character was
kind of supposed to be was kind of
conceived as being male that way when
she was being disobeyed member when her
orders got disobeyed to let it in it
kind of looked like man they were they
disobeyed her because she's a woman they
didn't trust her it kind of looked like
that yeah
was that added to the movie yeah but
that's not really what it was because
that that same thing happened in the
script when that when the when the
character was male yeah but I just you
know I know switching out the gender did
like you said it did do a lot of
interesting thing did a lot it Morgan to
which that yeah just because you know
because that's why it's kind of like Ned
Living Dead where you know the main
character wasn't written necessarily as
a black man but because he became a beep
to get back it actually gave the movie a
subtext that maybe it didn't even have
her they didn't really intend no but it
was happy because of that working out
better so I think the same thing
happened with alien yeah asking a woman
as ripple yeah because it's audience
expectation yeah and the expert you know
and it adds adds to it this one I could
tell that this character was written as
a female from the beat from the
beginning but they're trying to do the
exact same thing with Ripley yeah she
didn't do anything that was I mean she
just she was Mechanical Engineers yeah
this did what she was supposed to do
like on the job like when [ __ ] went
wrong she dude this is the protocol that
you follow that's not working okay so
I'm gonna figure this other thing out so
she just did ever there wasn't anything
in there that was light that screamed
girl at me no not really
yeah it's just it they were all they
were all some kind of specialist or some
kind of technician and she just happened
to be the mechanic yeah and it worked
out yeah we're that good a lot I liked
the movie yeah kind of reminded me of a
work environment movie work environment
or service or service related like a war
movie or something you know just like
that yeah I liked it but yeah like I
said this is it's interesting because it
seemed like the studio didn't really
have much faith in it to have kept it on
the shelf for so long and then dumped it
in jail yeah they're going this is Miley
and knock off and [ __ ] abyss and
Leviathan that shit's played out that's
exactly what they were thinking ago this
isn't going to do but they don't know
what they're talking about well the
thing it doesn't bother them to release
ripoffs of other movies yeah everything
they're also saying they don't know what
they're talking about everything's a
ripoff what's up yeah I thought it was
pretty much I just took the movie for
what it was and it the quality is it's a
high quality movie that I enjoyed yeah
and I was just like all right yeah it's
just a fun like scary underwater monster
I suppose I was into it you know nothing
nothing were less than that and like
alien you'd love it
yeah and I actually quite liked it
you
all right the third movie we're gonna be
talking about this week is also a
theater movie which actually started in
limited release on Christmas Day but we
didn't actually get until about a week
ago this is 1917 the war movie directed
by Sam Mendes who also did Skyfall and
also American Beauty which I think he
won a [ __ ] Oscar for if I'm not
mistaken this is also won several awards
so far and has been nominated for
several Oscars it's kind of based on
it's not based entirely on a true story
however it is based on director Sam
Mendes apparently this something that
his grandfather told him about something
that happened to him or his regiment or
someone that he knew like back in World
War one he's like it's not exactly the
same but that's where the germ of the
idea came from and he made the movie in
like homage to his paternal debt that's
something that we in the Army used to
call a war story all right and you know
being X infantry myself I understand the
culture of the infantry war stories
usually the [ __ ] tale all right and
this is based on a [ __ ] - okay go
ahead it's based on a [ __ ] tale well
anyway like I'm gonna say like I I'm
guessing it's really weird to me but I
guess you didn't like this movie I'm
like I really I really liked it I
thought of the movie that looked great
there were some really good scenes in it
but it was too realistic they're trying
to show realism all right or they're
trying to make you think that this is
that this is realism but then when you
see this story unfold you know I go
that's [ __ ] that didn't happen no no
no no no oh well it's your fault you
know I just kind of come from a culture
where you know I know training in World
War one wasn't really that good but
runners tended to be the best men that
they had and if this is the best men
that that British unit had then man I
think that the whole movie was an insult
to the British Army well like to do was
that the whole point of it and if you've
seen the trailer you kind of pretty much
know it's a very simple story you know
it's and it's based around like real
events that happened in April in 1917
whereas
the Germans retreated like back several
miles and they weren't entirely sure
like whether they were doing it as a
trap or whether it was like a legit
thing or something so the whole point
was that this there was this one regimen
and they had to go warn this other one
like not to attack because it was a trap
and they picked this one guy in
particular because his brother was in
the other regiment and they knew that he
would like try to get there as hard as
he could because I guess he wanted to
save his brother so they're trying to
save the lives of the 1600 men in the
other unit because they're pretty much
walking into a trap so the whole thing
it looks like it was shot in one take it
wasn't but the way it's shot makes you
think that so they actually did a really
good job of making it seem like the
whole thing was just one long take were
you just like following these two
soldiers like through this horrible
arduous journey that they are going on
but like I said it's not it's a little
bit of movie magic they didn't actually
do this all in one take but a lot of it
was done in very very long takes and
they just used like creative blocking
and things like that to make it look
like there were no edits I think the
only place that was a significant edit
was one time when the soldier like shot
the sniper and then he got knocked out
and then there was like a long period of
black like before he woke up again so I
think that was like the only time that I
noticed that there was an edit or like a
little bit of a time jump so the fact
that you have you know a soldier who has
you know a vested interest in getting to
this other place to avoid not only to
avoid getting these six hundred sixteen
hundred people killed but also to avoid
his brother dying so you had that
emotional investment there the other guy
that comes along he just kind of comes
along because he's the other guy's buddy
these because when they called them that
he didn't really know what he was
getting called for so that guy was kind
of like will [ __ ] me I didn't know this
was what was going to happen so they end
up having to go essentially across the
German frontlines you know and into the
trenches and everything like that like
trying to get to this other unit and no
one thinks they're gonna make it you
know I'm not gonna spoil like what
actually have
but it's basically just them going
across like trying to get to this other
regiment before morning so it's you know
all set within 24 hours um like I said I
really really liked this movie a lot I
got like really invested in this like
and there's like a bunch of like really
horrible [ __ ] that happens I mean it's
very realistic when they're like
climbing because we saw that [ __ ]
that documentary last year that was oh
the color eyes they got to look right
even got the sound right yeah it's like
explosions that's the way really that's
the way realistic you feel like you're
there there's [ __ ] dead bodies
everywhere that it's like nasty there's
dead horses T&T has a certain sound when
it goes off that sounded like a real TNT
type yeah I mean they really did try to
get everything as accurate as World War
one didn't they had and really perfected
high explosives but they had t they're
just so yes sound when you hear it you
know there's a concussive shockwave they
had the look and the feel right it's
just that it was just ridiculous I mean
had it been sold to me as a comedy I'd
probably would have liked it why did you
find it funny that that's [ __ ]
because those dudes are clowns
everything they did was the exact
opposite of what a real soldier would do
I mean they're talking to girls on their
way there fifteen hundred the lives of
fifteen hundred men are in the balance
and they're taking POWs and talking to
girls on the way and walking no you run
the whole way it wasn't very far it was
only a couple miles yeah it you they
can't run five miles
I'd have been down about what an hour
well like I said they were trying to get
like more emotionally and then they
runner they cared he runs across it runs
across German enemy soldiers who are
basically in his state of an unread eNOS
and you don't kill him he did he did
kill that one guy you know there was
three or four of them though you should
have her too he killed one and the other
one was drove for all that time yeah I
shot those [ __ ] look no it's not the
way it is when you have 1,600 or your
buddies when their lives are on the
lines you run to the objective you kill
or kill everyone and everyone in your
way man woman and child friendly or
enemy that's those stakes are very high
alright and it's running do it and if
you run across something
can't fight you you you avoid it I mean
there's a big building on fire he walks
up to it clearly silhouette and himself
making himself known it's just stupid
you know he caught he he the way he
crossed the river was just totally only
an idiot would have done that I just I
know it's World War one those guys were
not really you know kind of not trained
very well but runners tended to be their
best guys they weren't really picked at
random well at least you know I know the
Germans didn't pick him at random they
were kind of like their versions of
commandos and they were good at that
kind of [ __ ]
but no it is just to me I'm not to say
it was a bad movie I'm just gonna say
that it was a very entertaining movie
you know as far as like for comedic
value you know I mean just that it was
not based on a real story this is not
the way guys action know like I said he
didn't base it on a real story whose
base it on something that his
grandfather told him yet his grandfather
was doing something called telling war
stories yeah which is lying
you don't meet teenage girls in the
middle of a World War one battlefield
just didn't happen she was in a village
that was a village that was not a
village that was a fun that was a burned
down wreckage it was filled with Jeremy
Cruz and and if you had teenage girls
carrying babies and feeding baby it's
just totally implausible totally bald
and even if she was there they wouldn't
spend time talking to her well he was
wounded doesn't matter you run you know
yeah this is all superhuman feats he got
there and then [ __ ] lost his weapon
that really freaked me out
he lost his weapon and he kept going
it's just an embarrassment I thought you
know I was feeling embarrassed you don't
lose your weapon don't do it well I
liked the movie and no people seem to
like it to know so you know I saw it as
a glorification of incompetence I just
didn't you know I would have gotten in
big [ __ ] trouble had I done that that
kind of [ __ ] okay I'm just saying my
standards are much higher for military
movies than they are fun movies
especially one that's trying to sell it
realism to me yeah like I love army
movie like stripes it's just totally
ridiculous you know
or when's the name Private Benjamin
[ __ ] ridiculous that [ __ ] was I think
I like this but whenever you're trying
to sell me something that's supposed to
be realistic or just and it's not just
me because I said something about it I'm
Tom shady movies and all the other
veterans we're going yep that's right
you know they all then they hate them to
veterans hate war movies yeah basically
cuz there's a lot of [ __ ] in it well
like I said in fact I just kind of took
it as it's a movie it's not real life so
I always kind of like am I invest in
these characters do I want them to
finish their mission and you know am I
getting so I enjoyed it on that so I'm
not like constantly nitpicking abandoned
war movie of all time with Saving
Private Ryan
that was that was though yeah well I
like that maybe as that one's bruh that
was a good one you know um I remembered
hamburger hill being pretty good yeah I
like that
um but that's about it most of them
aren't very good the the Midway movie
that we saw that's pretty good
that's pretty close to what really
happened that was a little I don't know
letters from iwo jima was very good yeah
I like that one
Midway was all right but I felt like
that was a little too Hollywood yeah
yeah but actually though I think marine
warfare or naval warfare at that time
had a Hollywood quality those dudes were
I guess there's been a play wild add
especially the pilots they were wild
acid if I'm gonna see a war movie I'd
rather see one that was like more
realistic and not all like well no but I
mean like that just overdo everything
and it's like seems like massive
explosions like very Michael okay yeah
okay next time and it's like dodgy
characters I just can't
well that too but it's like I also can't
stand like all that over-the-top special
things like all the explosions are super
loud and super big and it's just kind of
like you know I did it just seems like a
lot of spectacle world war ii fighter
pilots where all i [ __ ] them well
you're all in it over the top happy
Boyington and all those guys they were
[ __ ] showboats yeah but they earned
that right
all right so anyway so if
you want to go see 19:17 and see if you
know what tom is talking about then go
check
[Music]